عاش السنوار، بالنسبة له، لقد انتصر بالفعل
لقد وجه لدولة إسرائيل ضربة قوية ونجح
أن يؤذيها بطريقة مؤلمة جداً ومن أجله
ستبقى خالدة في صفحات التاريخ كالأهداف التي صممت عليها
من قبل مجلس الوزراء
بالنسبة للحرب، تفكيك حماس لقدراتها العسكرية
وسياسة إعادة المختطفين وإعادة السلام إلى المنطقة المحيطة
إنها البداية وفي رأيي إنها أهداف تكتيكية
أنها لا ترضي خالق الوعي والإدراك
من المؤكد أن النصر لا يكفي لحرق وعي الخسارة
على الجانب الآخر، سوف يمر الوقت وستظهر منظمة قاتلة جديدة
وخلق قدرات جديدة لنفسه.رأينا
وأحدث استطلاع حول المواقف بين الفلسطينيين أيضا
ونحن نرى أنهم جميعا يقفون مثل الجدار
بطريقة خلف نطاق السابع من أكتوبر
وألوان الرغبة من حماس شديدة جدًا، لذا فقد حان الوقت
توقف عن تحقيق المزيد والمزيد من الانتصارات التكتيكية
حان الوقت لتحقيق نصر استراتيجي على الهدف
الحرب يجب أن تكون سيطرة دولة إسرائيل على كل شيء
من قطاع غزة ليس لمدة أسبوع ولا أسبوعين ولكن
وإلى الأبد، كانت غزة دولة إسرائيل
والمودة يجب أن تعود أراضي من البلاد إلى هذا
و